[Música]
y en directo a América de France 24
vamos a hacer un repaso por lo que
titula la prensa internacional por ello
ya me acompaña en el estudio de mi
compañera Marta Moya Marta Buenos días
Hola Valentina Buenos días Buenos días
de jueves ya casi terminando la semana
por fin vamos a abrir esta revista de
prensa con las portadas de los medios
franceses que reportan este creciente
malestar social contra la policía esto
Al Calor de lo que estábamos hablando
del asesinato de un joven al que un
agente le disparó a quemar ropa Así es
Valentina vamos a dar un poquito más de
contexto es la segunda noche de
disturbios en Francia tanto en París
como en otras ciudades del país galo
después de que un policía de 38 años
disparará a quemarropa a un joven de 17
que iba en un carro junto a tres
personas y que se negó a detenerse
frente a un control policial el suceso
se dio en nanter en un suburbio parisino
y ha despertado la indignación colectiva
por las conductas desproporcionadas
abusivas e incluso ile de parte de los
policías en el ejercicio de sus
funciones por todo ello la prensa
francesa hoy es monográfica en sus
portadas impresas Al Calor de este tema
vamos a empezar con Liberación que
titula policía a la deriva y en la foto
vemos ese momento en el que los agentes
increpan al joven con el arma esto se
dio el martes por la mañana en el
subtítulo de liberación se dice el
episodio pone de manifiesto profundos
fallos de una institución Intocable y se
pregunta hasta cuándo Por otra parte
hemos destacado la portada de la quake
titula los métodos de la policía bajo
cuestionamiento y se ven a los agentes
en medio de estos disturbios de las
últimas horas que ha dejan al menos 150
detenidos por otra parte Le paguesían tú
la incomprensible y utiliza la misma
foto que Liberación para retratar lo
trágico del episodio Por otra parte
humanity titula violencia policial la
muerte de muchos la muerte de Este joven
de 17 años atestigua dice yo manité la
deriva violenta de la policía y los
llamados a una reforma del código de
seguridad que entre ellos piden que
desaparezcan las brigadas motorizadas
que incluyen a dos policías por moto y
que se instauraron Al Calor de las
marchas de los chalecos amarillos en el
año 2018 por terminar hemos destacado la
portada de la Depeche midi este
periódico de toulouse que dice la muerte
de nael también desencadena la violencia
en la propia toulouse los ánimos están
caldeados dice este medio y dan muestra
de que la indignación es transversal en
toda Francia bueno Marta vamos a cambiar
de tema y vamos a seguir con lo que
podemos decir es el desarrollo de una
novela rusa que implica al líder al
líder del grupo Wagner y a la de alto
general ruso que según la inteligencia
estadounidense sabía de los planes de
revelarse contra Putin hay medios que
dicen que está arrestado otros que está
desaparecido Pues a ver vamos a empezar
con el most you Times que es el medio
concretamente que dice que es sergeistín
estaría arrestado y lo confirma así con
Fuentes atribuidas al Ministerio de
defensa
recordemos la polémica se desata el
martes por la noche cuando el York Times
publica una información en exclusiva en
la que dice que este alto general ruso
sabría de los planes de
prigong de rebelarse contra el kremlin
la información que publica el Moscú Time
se atribuye concretamente a dos Fuentes
bajo condición de anonimato del
Ministerio de defensa el primer rumor
sin embargo lo distribuyó un bloguero
Ruso el 25 de Julio concretamente
Vladimir romanov y no se sabe de su
paradero no se sabe del paradero de
surviquín ni siquiera entre los
funcionarios del ministerio una de las
fuentes del mosqui Times dice
textualmente Aparentemente eligió el
bando de goji y lo agarraron de las
pelotas Muchos medios se han hecho Eco
De esta información entre ellos el
independen ucraniano que sin embargo
dice que no puede confirmar estas
informaciones sin embargo hay otros
medios más conservadores con esta
información que no dicen que está
arrestado pero dicen que el ser gay
surobikin en estos momentos está
desaparecido entre ellos lo destaca el
británico de Guardian que dice que el
general ruso no ha sido visto en público
desde el pasado sábado mandó un video
apoyando a Putin el viernes por la noche
pero desde entonces no se sabe nada de
su paradero Además este artículo del
Guardian que hemos destacado destaca la
buena relación entre surviquín y prigong
sobre todo porque prigollin celebró su
nombramiento en 2022 como líder de las
fuerzas armadas en la ofensiva ucraniana
y lo definió como una figura legendaria
a raíz de estas informaciones especula
si surobiquín podría ser purgado o
investigado por este presunto apoyo a la
rebelión del grupo Wagner Aunque
analistas citados por el Guardian dicen
o se muestran escépticos de que tuviera
una implicación directa en toda esta
revuelta Asimismo se pronuncia el dails
en Estados Unidos que se pregunta dónde
está surobiquín y publica las diferentes
hipótesis que hay Al Calor de toda esta
novela y dice que Moscú y está
investigando sobre el presunto apoyo a
la rebelión de Wagner y que podría esto
dar pistas sobre cómo están los niveles
de lealtad a Putin al interno de Rusia y
el Daily beast dice que ese nivel de
lealtad se podría estar desintegrando
entre bambalinas Bueno lo que usted dice
si algo sabemos es que no ha aparecido
en público Así que estaremos pendientes
a conocer detalles Marta vamos ahora con
un análisis del orden mundial hoy titula
drones sensores y perros robots la
distopía del control en las fronteras
pues Valentina es un análisis Que firma
Julia codina y dice que tanto en Europa
como en Norteamérica se están
implementando
tecnologías inteligentes para controlar
y vigilar las fronteras entre estas
tecnologías drones cámaras perros robot
datos biométricos o sensores de
movimiento los gobiernos justifican la
implementación de estas tecnologías para
mantener el control de las fronteras
recordemos que el año pasado más de 100
millones de personas se desplazaron de
sus lugares de origen por diversas
cuestiones en la Unión Europea Grecia
letonia Hungría han implementado una
suerte de guardia fronteriza virtual que
hace preguntas a las personas que
transitan por la frontera para dejarlos
pasar o no es la propia tecnología la
que pues tiene que decidir si Confía en
las respuestas de los migrantes o no les
deja pasar dice este análisis de el
orden mundial que esto sin embargo ha
generado Mucho racismo y vulnera los
derechos humanos de los migrantes porque
sigue habiendo racismo en la detección
facial y sigue habiendo muchos controles
exhaustivos la población negra y árabe
dice textualmente este Tec no
solucionismo solo aumenta la
criminalización de los migrantes que
cruzan fronteras y las narrativas
extremistas que avivan los sentimientos
antimigración en el mundo bueno y Esto
justamente cuando se está debatiendo la
ley de Inteligencia artificial se
opusieron en principio el parlamento
europeo a estas técnicas de vigilancia
masiva Pero hay una llave abierta de una
puerta abierta que todavía hay que
discutir efectivamente Y a ver si se
debate en esta reunión que tienen los
líderes en Bruselas estos días pues
vamos a ver qué sale de allí vamos a
terminar con una nota del Washington
post bastante triste que alerta que la
histórica revista National Geographic
está despidiendo a sus últimos empleados
de planta pues y Valentina concretamente
a los últimos 19 empleados editoriales
de National Geographic a partir de ahora
los artículos de esta revista mensual
los van a firmar freelance son los
segundos despidos en nueve meses los
cuartos Desde que la dirección de esta
revista cambió de propietario en el año
2015 a partir del año que viene la
revista también dejará de imprimirse
solo va a poder consultarse a partir de
una suscripción web y es un golpe no
para una de las revistas más consumidas
en Estados Unidos y que bueno ahora como
muchas de las de la fauna que ha
retratado esta en peligro de extinción
Bueno pues nosotros Seguiremos fieles a
la revista esto es una pena pero aquí
aquí nos mantenemos Marta Muchas gracias
por esta ampliación Gracias Valentina